チャプターは変わります
必要でしょうか？集中力はという
成長のエネルギー資源
だから成長のエネルギー資源だから集中力は必要なんです
これ エネルギーなんです
成長しないと退化する
昨日より今日は良い人間になると思って生活しなくてはならないんです
知識も知恵も開発しなくてはならないんです
そのために集中力が必要です
できないと思われることをできるようになる
期待通りかそれよりも良い結果が出る
精進することは楽しくなるという集中力の
もうちょっと戻します
集中力のいいところいっぱいあるんです
自分ではできそうとも思わなかったものなんですけど
集中力でもできるんですよ
まあ例えば 50歳  60歳になっても
初めてピアノを触ってね
上手になりますよ たった集中力さえあれば
できます 普通はね  4歳で
5歳で始めなくてはいけないと言ってるでしょ
まあ一生それにかかった人は上手かもしれませんだけど
まあそれなりに適当に弾けるようにはなりますよ
もう 60歳で始めたって
ということで 集中力っていうのは必要でしょうかではなくて必要です
それから皆さん 仕事やら勉強やら頑張ってるでしょ？苦しいでしょ
あれは 毎日やっていることは集中力さえあれば苦しくないんです
だから集中力っていうのはとてもありがたいことなんです
集中力の秘密 だから秘密を明かしますので
これから集中力を自由にしてください
能率効率ばかり気にすると
心に汚れが入るので集中力は向上するのではなく
減ってしまうんです だからみんな集中力って言った途端
集中力あったら能率は上がるぞと思っちゃうでしょうね
それで減るんです これ分からなくて
あんた集中しなさい もっと能率上がりますよと
って言っちゃうと これダメなんです
上がらないんです 集中して勉強しなさい
すぐ覚えられますよと
頭が良くなります と言った途端
集中力が消えるんです
だから誰もしたりしてないんだから
集中力の世界を 仏教以外は
これがかなりの秘密なんです
集中力自体は楽しいんです
これを覚えてください
集中力自体が楽しいんです
能率はどうでもいいんです
効率そんなのはどうでもいいんです
これが楽しいんです 集中力あることは
だから集中したらよく頭良くなりますよではなくて
面白いよと楽しくなるんだよと言わなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 人が上手に仕事をしたってもね
集中力なく ただ能力で仕事をバリバリしていますけどね
面白くないんだけど 集中力あったらすごい超面白いんだよと言った方がいいんです
だから言ってはいけない言葉と言うべき言葉が 2つあります
これですよ 秘密って言えば
あ なんとかなった この楽しみを大事にすると集中力は向上するんです
この楽しみを大事にするんです
釈尊はこの楽しみ 楽 喜悦
喜を中心にして語るんです
お釈迦様は集中力について語る場合は
集中力 集中力と単語あまり使わないんです
ハイライトするのはこの楽しみのことなんです
こんな楽しみがあるんだよと
こんな楽しみもあるんだよと
それでみんな集中力が育てるんです
まあこれ 喜と喜びですね
仏教は喜悦を目指す教えではないんです
楽しみ 楽しみで言ったら
仏教にはそんな興味ないんです
人を喜ばせてあげるとかね
解脱 無執着に挑戦する過程で現れるものだと知っているだけ
仏教は解脱しなさい 執着捨てなさいと言ってる世界ですよ
しかし これ解脱すると
この頑張ってる途中で楽しいんだよと
苦しくないんだよと 無執着になろうと頑張ってみると
これ楽しくてたまらんやという話なんです
だから楽しみを目指せとも言わないんです
楽しみをハイライトするんです
お釈迦様の親戚の兄弟であるある人が出家して
王子でしたからね もうかなりの豊かな家で
出家してから一人ぼっち
一人で森の中 いろんなところで生活しているんです
それですごい贅沢三昧で生きていたことをみんな知っているんです
それで このお坊さんが
ああ なんと楽しいな なんと楽しいなと
いつでも口癖で言うんです
なんて楽しいことか なんと楽しいことかというと
周りのお坊さんたちがちょっと誤解してたんですね
この人はもう才気でね
お釈迦様の親戚でもあるし
無茶贅沢していたんだと
王子様で 今は出家して
一人ぼっちで托鉢でご飯食べて
木の下で寝て 家もなく
こんな苦しい人生をやってるんだから
おそらく宮殿のことを思い出してるでしょうと
宮殿のことを思い出して
ああ 楽しいなと思っている
頭で妄想してると思ったんです
宮殿の生活を いてお釈迦様に報告したら
お釈迦様はこれまずいと呼んだんだ
その人は君 楽しい 楽しいって何かいつでも口癖で言ってるのは本当ですか？と
そう ちょっとすぐ漏れますよと
言葉と言うんですね まあすぐなんとか言うだけの
まあ独り言でね 独り言は言いますよと
癖で あのね 何が楽しいのかと
お釈迦様は具体的に聞くんです
楽しい 何が楽しいの？と言ったら
この人答えるんです お釈迦様
私は宮殿にいた時はね
24時間軍隊に警備されていたんだよ
24時間 どこへ行ってもしっかりとガードマンがついていたんだよと
しかし 毎日怯えていたんだと
夜もろくに寝られないんだよ
警備もうるさいし 今はね
誰も私を守ってくれませんよと
一人で生活していますよと
しかし 心は穏やかで 恐怖感みじんもなく
夜寝られないとかね そんな精神問題は何もなく
常に穏やかにいるんだと
だから 木を見ても 山を見ても
川を見ても 私にはすぐそこ
川のそばで そこでちょっと腰をかけてご飯を食べる時
すぐ思い出せますと だから今なんて幸せかということ
そこをすぐ口癖と言いますよと
今は心に欲もなく 怒りもなく
無知もないんだよと 何にも執着していないんだよと
だから究極に楽しいと言ったら
その通りですよと だからみんなの前で言ったんだから
大らかにね いちいち文句を言うなよとということになったんです
だから楽しいんですよ
私たちは楽しみをある程度で知っています
皆様もある程度で楽しみ知っています
楽しいなら幸福だと思っている
楽しい 楽しいことできれば私は幸福だ
幸福だとも言ってるんです
何かに引っかかっていることで楽しみを得るんです
何かに引っかかって楽しみを得るんです
これは喜まで発達していないんです
これ 私たちはね 何か本読んで楽しいとかね
まあいろいろ稽古事ができて
年取っているのにね 楽しいとかいろいろ言うでしょう
だからそれは何かに引っかかって楽しいっていうことなんですが
喜という言葉で表すほど今日レベル高い楽しみじゃないんです
楽しみと嬉しいっていうこと
物に依存して得られるんですね
楽しみは 楽しいから本を読む
楽しくない場合は読みたくはないということね
読んでも集中力がなくなるんですね
楽しくない本を読んでも集中力がなくなるんです
楽しい本を読むと集中力が生まれてくるんです
楽しいから本を読んで得られる楽しみにも制限があります
今 本の例だけ出してます
だから楽しい本を読んで読んで読んで
究極に集中力をさせると思ってもできないんです
この楽しみは悪感情で汚れているならば
なおさら危険でもあります
だから楽しいからやりましょうと言っても気をつけましょう
楽しいことをやると 当然集中力は生まれますが
この楽しみは何なのかと
これ悪い感情だったらとても危険です
それだけ 不幸なことに
必要なことを 大事なことを
幸福に 成長に関わることをやろうとすると楽しくないんですよ
でしょ 勉強は楽しくないしね
仕事もそんな楽しくはないし
大事なこと 楽しくないんです
くだらない もう堕落することだったらもうやりたいんです
悪いことなら楽しくてたまらないんですね
普通は ですから 自然的な楽しみは危険ですが
楽しみは悪いのではないんです
子供に聞けばゲームが楽しいんだけど
宿題は楽しくないんですね
ゲームで何も得られませんよ
宿題をすると何か得するものがあるのに
得するものがか もう楽しくないんですね
だから集中力も出てこない
だから楽しくないんだからやりたくない
その代わりにゲームならやりますと
楽しいんだから しかし
そこを気をつけましょう
それは大変なことになっています
楽しみが悪いじゃないんです
別なところなんです 必要な本を読む時
楽しくなるように工夫すれば良いと思います
だからどうしましょうか
楽しい本を探して読むんじゃなくて
必要な本を探して読む
しかし 楽しくないでしょ
楽しくなるようにわざとするんです
勉強の本を読む時はわざと楽しみにするんです
今はもう楽しみで数学の本を読んでいるんだそうとかね
数学の問題もいろいろ解決しているんだそうとかね
今はもう楽しく 今はフランス語に挑戦している
楽しくてたまらないんだよ
というまあ フランス語を勉強すると思ったっても
この動詞の 英語でデクレンションと言うんですけど
あれ変化を覚えなくちゃあかんですよ
たくさんあります 聞いただけで嫌になっちゃうんです
でも私がやっていた時は結構楽しくやりましたけど
すぐ忘れちゃったんです
で だから勉強などは楽しくやればいいんです
楽しくなる方法は何なのかというと
これ自分で発見するんですよ
ちょっと例を出します
必要な本ですが 難しくて読みづらいでしょ
そこで理性を働かせます
動かします 中身をあらゆる角度で見てみる
一つでただただ読むんじゃなくて
いろんな角度でこれ考えてみる
読む内容を分析してみる
じゃあこれでこれでこれでとか分析してみる
それから自分の意見を入れて考えてみる
その本で言っていることについて
自分が何言いたいのかどうかね
もう一人の遊だから何でもできます
他人に教えてあげる場合はどうすれば良いのかと考えてみる
これも一つの方法なんで
自分が本を読みながら自分のために本を読んでいるので
誰も教えてくださいと言わないんですが
この内容は人に教える場合はどうすればいいかと
そうするとギャーギャー言っただけで聞いてくれないでしょ？自分が面白くプレゼンテーションしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから頭の中でシミュレーションするんですよ
難しい本を読みながら
この教えるシミュレーションしたりする
そうすると何のことなく楽しくてもう本は終わっているんです
内容もしっかり覚えているんです
これ 本を読む場合ですね
このように工夫すると楽しくなります
他の必要な仕事の場合も
それなりの工夫をして楽しみを見出す見出すんです
まあ間違いたくさんありますけども
今時間がないんです で
楽しくなければやらないというわがままを
楽しみを見つける工夫に変えるんです
大体みんな楽しくなければやれないってわがままでしょ
これでいいんです わがままを楽しくなければやらないと言って
あれこれやめるんじゃなくて
何やっても楽しくやればいいんです
わがままだがいいんです
だから私が言いたいのは
何やっても楽しくやりなさいよと
楽しみを見つかりなさいよ
ありますよ 皆様 頭が鈍っているだけで
小さな子供を見てください
すぐ楽しいの見つかりますから
どこ連れて行っても 知らないところ連れて行っても
1分以内でもうなんとかやっているんです
くぐることできれば 何でやってもくぐってみたりする
登ることがこれ登れるさということで登るんです
だからもうどこへ連れて行っても
子供はすぐ楽しみを見つかるんだから
だからなんで大人にできないんですか
うれしいとはほとんど突然起こる出来事に対して言っているようですね
嬉しく生きることは従って無理でしょう
嬉しく生きるっていうことはちょっと無理だと思います
突然起こることに嬉しいと言うんです
ですから 楽しく生きることにしましょう
嬉しく生きるんじゃなくて
楽しく生きるということにします
で 楽しみは脳の栄養 脳の開発には楽しみが必要です
これは食べる楽しみなどとは違います
知恵の開発にも楽しみが必要になる
やがて楽しみも乗り越えて
冷静という境地に立って解脱を体験する
楽しみを通らない冷静は要注意です
この順番です 脳が開発しませんよ
楽しくないと 楽しくないと何も進まないんです
世の中成長なくなるんです
破壊するんです 大いに楽しみを見つけた方がいいんです
だから楽しみ 額みたいに悪い楽しみ
破壊 楽しみと良い楽しみと仏教はちゃんと明確にしています
えーと これで楽しみから発展して発展して
頂点に立ったところで楽しみも捨てるんです
捨てる冷静 ということになるんです
冷静になって解脱に達するんです
なのに 何もやってないんだけど
すごい冷静な人っているんですよ
仏教は勉強始めたばっかしなんですけど
私はまあ世の中のこと
すごく冷静でこうでいるんだよとかね
興味がないよと言ったり
私はちょっと怪しいと思いますね
で 要注意です 順番がありますからね
まず楽しみ これがうまく進んだら冷静なんです
無関心 無知も冷静の錯覚を起こすんですからです
無関心でいること 無知でいることも冷静に見えるんです
これが危ない これはもう悪い
悪感情 はい 早く進みます
楽しみの度合い 私たちはなんとなく楽しみを感じている
たまに涙がこぼれるような楽しみあるが稀です
ですから 普通の楽しみは脳細胞の中だけ起こる反応になっているんです
我々思う楽しみでも 脳細胞だけでくると
ちょっと反応だけなんですね
しかし 楽しく生きるなら
その影響は体にも表れるんです
もし我々は毎日楽しく生きると
この脳だけの反応が体まで表れていくんです
病気も老けるスピードも減るんです
だから楽しく生きるということは大事なんです
単なる感覚的に楽しいだけではなくて
どんどん病気も減ったりして
老けるスピードも減ったりします
でお釈迦様がサマーディ瞑想で集中力を育てることを推薦しているんです
お釈迦様が特別に集中力育てる方法を教えてあります
初めに五欲に依存して楽しみを得ることを置いておく
まず この何かやってご飯食べて映画を見て楽しもうという
このものに依存する感情的な楽しみを置いておくんです
それよりレベル高い楽しみを得ることに挑戦するんです
こんな品のない楽しみではなくて
すごいレベル高い楽しみを得ようと
得ようとするんです 損はしません
五欲捨てたんだからといって暗くなるわけじゃないんです
より高い楽しみを得るんです
五欲で戯れることは惜しいと思うと
その作業は無理ですね
ブッダの作業はできなくなるんです
惜しいなと思っちゃうと
サマーディから最初に得られる喜びという波動は
脳だけに限るものではありません
お釈迦様の楽しみの見つけ方やると
これは脳だけの反応では終わらないんです
体全体に行き渡る楽しみ
喜びです それは第一線上で喜びに満ちてない心はないところは
体の中にどこにもありませんと説いているんです
ちょっと瞑想で集中力を育てると楽しいんです
どこまで楽しいかというと
細胞一個もないんで 楽しみで触れなくて
触れてないもの 細胞一個一個まで感じるんです
その楽しみは 普段は絶対感じることができません
で 皆様にはちょっと理解もできないかもしれません
指先までもう体全体に楽しみ感じるんです
だからお釈迦様はたとえ話持ってくるんです
わからないんだから 水でよく練った泥団子のたとえを使っているんです
あの泥をね よく水で練って泥団子を作るんです
そういう泥団子の中で水に濡れてないところはどこにもありません
だから泥で団子を作って
この団子の中で水がないところはどこでしょうかということなんです
どこにも水が入っている
そのようにちょっと集中力を育てると
お釈迦様が言うとおり
体全体に喜びになるんです
だから結果は違います
で 徐々にサマーディの向上とともに喜びの度合いも上がるんです
第 3 戦場で喜びが人の存在を完全支配するんです
なんか喜びが一人勝手に歩いちゃって
自分を抑えてしまうところまでいくんです
心の中で喜ぶところじゃないんです
喜びに潰されるんです
それぐらい喜びという喜びが大きくなるんです
たとえあります 涼しい巨大な湖の中で生えた蓮の花が水の中で咲いてしまう
もう巨大なネパールの地を想像してください
結構涼しい湖がありますね
その中で蓮の花が生えて
一本の花が上に来ない
水の中で出て 水の中で大きくなって花が咲く
そこで そのハスの花は涼しい水で触れてますね
どんな状態で？巨大な湖が涼しい
喜びなんです 自分の存在はちっちゃなハスの花なんです
花は自分で 巨大な湖の涼しい水は喜びです
そこまで喜びは成長するんです
今 我々にというと 私の楽しみってほんの小さな楽しみの脳の中で起こる
微妙に微笑むぐらいで終わっちゃうんです
ちゃんと集中力育てるとそんなもんじゃなくて
それが巨大な湖のように大きくなって
自分が小さくなるんです
喜びから冷静 第4専行
あまり説明しないんですが
ちょっと省略します たとえ話やります
涼しいところで人は白い布を頭から足までかぶって寝ている
その人の体には白い布で覆われてないところはない
この場合は自分がいるという苦しみさえもない
冷静の気持ちです この喜び乗り越えたら冷静になるんです
冷静になった状態をお釈迦様は説明するのは
ものすごく夏 真夏で 人が涼しい湖に入り込んで
よく体をきれいにして
それから涼しいところで白い布をかぶってグーグーと寝ている
頭から足まで全部布でかぶっておくんです
そうすると その人の体
全部白い布でかぶされているし
本人が寝ているんです
俺が隠れているんだと
その気持ちさえないんです
いわゆる自分がいるという煩わしいことさえもないのが冷静な状態なんです
楽しいなら何でもやれるのは当然なので
正しい集中力を育てようとすると簡単です
だから集中力 集中力で嫌な顔で聞くんじゃなくて
楽しみだ 楽しみだと思わなくちゃあかんです
みんなの集中力ないのは
それってまた堅苦しいことやと思って
これが集中力ないってことなんで
これ楽しみなんです  うん